one of the most common performance
questions we get with respect to Google
cloud storage is related to what type of
bucket should I use for the best
performance which is a really good
question when you create a new GCS
bucket one of the first things you need
to do is decide what type of storage
class it has and while the text there is
descriptive there's not a lot of room to
discuss all the performance nuances
generally these classes can be broken
into two categories near line and cold
line are built for content which is
accessed infrequently and thus latency
shouldn't really be considered when
fetching from regional and
multi-regional however are expected to
serve data as fast as possible so what
are those terms actually mean though
well a regional GCS bucket guarantees
that all the data in that bucket lies in
a specified region which you determine
when you create the bucket this type of
location is really important in
situations where you know where your
client are on Prem systems are located
and you want to get your GCS buckets as
close to those systems as possible
multi-regional storage on the other hand
guarantees two replicas of your data
which are geo diverse about 100 miles
apart or so this results in the data
being moved between regions for better
latency and availability more
importantly is that multi-regional
heavily leverages edge caching and CDNs
to provide content to the end users as
fast as possible to understand how these
systems respond under stress we set up a
simple test upload a two megabyte file
to a bunch of regional and
multi-regional buckets and fetch that
essay with caching disabled from a VM in
uswest one first there's a couple of
things that we can discern from this
data for fetches in the same region or
in a sub region of the multi region
performance is pretty on par however
once we get across oceans we can see
that the multi-regional buckets tend to
perform better the reason for this is
that their data was duplicated to a
region of the multi region which
provides better access point and lower
latency to our fetching clients what
these tests show us is that there's no
really specific performance different of
the classifications of the buckets
themselves rather the performance is
dominated by the latency of physics of
the distance between the clients and the
cloud storage bucket how
to be clear with caching on your read
performance for both regional and
multi-regional should look something
like this
so if caching is on Google's powerful
CDN can help improve your read
performance regardless of the bucket but
if caching is off then it's best to pick
a class that puts your content as close
to your endpoints as possible so learn
more about the perf details of these
buckets check out the article linked in
the description below and don't forget
to check out the rest of our cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts